in hang on there are all kinds of d  season dc just winning on the spot yeah  you have to go queen d2 right you can't  take queen d3 because but then knight c4  it's over yeah dc and it's over oh wow  and look at this andre i cannot believe  yeah that he has he has this incredible  chance he's enjoying himself i'm gonna  miss this he's not gonna miss this he's  double clipper checking i think he  already seen the move dc that's what i'm  getting from his body  language let's have this line on the  board let's just uh show what you do  it's on the board already this is played  so the point is that queen d3 your f2 is  and level designs yeah level of these  lines immediately unbelievable  what is and queen d2 the only square to  keep f2 under control as peter you were  saying knight c4 now there are no good  squares and f2 falls and everything  falls and this was a very quick win for  andreas penco peter this means  levon is  out